let me take a moment here before we
start digging into hatred mail and much
more to thank Linda Fisher who's today's
new member of the day our program is
mostly funded by people like you people
just like you in more ways than you know
including that they want to support
independent media like the David Pakman
show
you can join Linda Fisher at WWE in
pac-man comm you can also use the coupon
code this is 20/20 to save 40% off of
the cost of your membership and I want
to thank Kelly Mar who is today's
longtime sustaining member of the day
with us nearly five years thanks to
Linda thanks to Kelly look forward to
welcoming you as a new member of the day
someday soon okay it's time for this
week's edition of hatred male hatred
male is when a professional voice-over
artist does interpretive readings of
hatred mail that I get quick reminder
teachers can buy their own school
supplies but will throw in the Glock for
free Patriot mail written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America
and because freedom okay so this week's
hatred mail yes it contains
anti-semitism that's not rare but it
also includes their I didn't even
realize that this took off until I
received a number of emails about it
when FoxNews accidentally put up an
image that implied Supreme Court Justice
Ruth Bader Ginsburg had passed away it
said her birth year to 2019 and they put
it up for like a second and then
apologized a bunch of people who email
me believe that it's actually true that
Ruth Bader Ginsburg has passed away and
that there's a conspiracy to hide that
so that Donald Trump doesn't get to
select a new Supreme Court justice
anyway this week's hatred mail combines
the anti-semitism we have come to be
accustomed to in hatred mail with this
RBG conspiracy Ruth Bader Ginsberg evil
old Zionist Jews sodomite which is dead
Fox News made a mistake can David Pakman
beta's Zionist Jews sodomites prove Ruth
Bader Ginsburg is still alive these sick
heartless ruthless Zionist Jews want to
continue with their lives of RBG being
alive so that president Trump's can't
pick another constitutional judge of his
choice they want to drag this shenanigan
monkey business as long as they can
where is Harvey lo TMZ Jonah Bray Massey
only heir bad fake news about our
president Trump First Lady Melania and
other good traditional [ __ ] check-marked
yeah I don't know that I can really add
too much to this other than to say that
this if we imagine a time capsule that
would be sent to generations elsewhere
in the universe if indeed intelligent
life exists this is what we need to bury
at all costs because it's inclusion in
any kind of communication with other
intelligent species can only spell doom
for the future of Homo sapiens on the
planet Earth
use the coupon code hey tree at 42 send
a middle finger salute to the hatreds
and to save 40% when you sign up for a
membership at WWE pakman.com the coupon
code is h80 our IOT 4-0